this episode is sponsored by surf shark
get surfsharkvpn at surfshark.deals
microcosmos and enter promo code
microcosmos for an 83 discount and three
extra months for free
ronifers don't really get a lot of love
when it comes to microscopic animals
at least as far as the public
imagination goes
the rotifer is overshadowed by its
fellow metazoan of the microcosmos the
tardigrade
[Music]
and we might be part of the problem
in the first few months of the channel
we did spend an entire episode on our
rotifer friends
but despite how often they show up in
our videos spinning their wheels we have
many more videos focused on tardigrades
and we even made a tardigrade t-shirt
of course there is a very simple
explanation for this
tardigrades are weird looking but
they're also kind of cute
at times they may even seem kind of
cuddly
rotifers on the other hand well
they're mostly just weird
very cool but also very weird
but rotifers are making a bit of a
comeback a very literal one
this year researchers announced that
they were able to recover a living
rotifer frozen inside 24 000 year old
permafrost collected from a river in
northeastern siberia
while some species of rotifers have been
noted for their tardigrade-like ability
to withstand long periods of low
temperatures
scientists had previously observed those
periods to be more on the order of six
to ten years that's still a pretty
impressive amount of time to survive
freezing conditions
but it's a far cry from 24 000 years
this doesn't mean that we should be
expecting ancient rotifers to be popping
out of the ground or anything
it's just that it's so remarkable to
imagine a world where tardigrades aren't
alone in their complex bodies and
resilient capabilities
and then to realize that world isn't
imaginary
that rotifers have been right there
alongside them the whole time
and so today we want to take a moment to
appreciate the rotifer from the inside
out
with many animals that would require
dissection
but fortunately for us a little bit of
strong light and our most recent
microscope updates lets us see the inner
mach nations of the rotifer at work
it's almost like we're on a field trip
huddled together on some kind of magic
school bus as we journey through the
organism itself
[Music]
all around us is a living exhibit made
up of around 1 000 cells
that number of cells will stay constant
over the course of the rotifer's
lifetime
but there are also about 2 400 known
species of rotifers
which means there have been at least 2
400 ideas of just how to put 1000 cells
to good use
so what we'll be seeing today are just
some of those uses
because it turns out there are many many
many different ways to actually be a
rotifer and to actually look like a
rotifer
but different as they may be there are a
few traits that unite these strange
swimming organisms
including what will be the first stop on
our tour
this is the corona the moving hairy
crown atop the rotifer that gives it the
name wheel bearer
it will look different for different
species but the spinning headband shares
one specific purpose
to stir up the water and bring food to
the rotifer
then the food will pass on to another
part shared by all rotifers their jaw
also called the trophy which is settled
into a muscular structure called the
mastex you can see it at work here
opening and closing inside the rotifer's
head as it passes food from the head to
the rest of its body
jaws have evolved many times in the
animal kingdom over the past 500 million
years or so
which means that you can find a lot of
different jaws out there in the wild
even among rotifers there are at least
nine different types of trophy that we
know of and their shape depends on the
diet of the rotifer
and as you look around at the trophy
what you're seeing is an engineering
marvel
there are at least seven distinct parts
to it
each with their own set of actions that
they perform over the rotifer's lifetime
without wearing down or breaking
they grab they crush they pierce
it's like a tiny little machine inside
the rotifer which is why researchers
have even looked to the trophy as
inspiration for future tiny little
robots
does that mean we can expect a rotifer
robot anytime soon
probably not
but who needs robots when we've got the
real life thing right here in front of
us
the trophy's main purpose is to pass
food from the outside to the inside
which takes us to our next and perhaps
most perilous stop the stomach with its
enzymes designed to break down food
though if the rotifer is male you might
not actually have to watch out after all
because
there might not be a stomach
because they just don't live long enough
to need one
rotifer species differ in how they
approach the necessity of males
there are some that have done away with
the concept of males entirely
relying on asexual reproduction to
survive
others will keep them around for a short
time though primarily for sexual
reproduction
these male rotifers are smaller and
their survival lasts just long enough to
allow them to fertilize eggs
so returning our attention to the female
rhodifer's body
we can see the oocyte in the ovary
nested in a tissue called the
vitillarium when food is plenty the
vitillarium can provide rna protein and
liquid droplets to the oocyte
so that it swells and swells
pushing the rest of the organs around
until finally the egg is released
the last up on this tour de rotifer is
the foot
which even extends into a toe but unlike
our toes the rotifer toe has a cement
gland in it
producing a glue that keeps the rotifer
stuck to whatever surface appeals to
them at least that's the case for many
rotifers as they stretch out from a
single anchor point and put their
frantic crowns to work
but some rotifers don't want to be tied
down
they prefer a more mobile lifestyle
these planktonic rotifers might end up
in the open waters where there isn't
much vegetation to crawl around on or to
stick to
so they just don't they might forego a
foot all together
instead they swim around on occasion
even using the cilia on the crowns to
help them
but if they bump up against a predator
or something else that makes them
uncomfortable
they can do something you might not
usually imagine rotifers doing
they jump
they can do this because they have
paddles
to see them we have to return to where
we started
to the front of the rotifer
where these striated blades make up the
planktonic rotifer's jumping apparatus
they work incredibly quickly
taking only about seven milliseconds to
get going if a rotifer has made contact
with a predator
as we've traveled through the rotifer's
body we've seen just how much can be
made with so little
and should we live in a future filled
with resurrected ancient rotifers and
robotic modern ones
then perhaps we will appreciate them
not for the cute tardigrades they aren't
but for the intricate little living
machines that they are
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you to surf shark for
sponsoring this episode streaming rights
are complicated and some of your
favorite shows might not be available to
you based on your location but with a
vpn you can access movies and shows that
are only available in other countries
from wherever you are by using vpn
servers in the countries where they're
available
so say i want to get into the halloween
spirit and want to watch the first
friday the 13th movie
well it's not currently available on any
u.s streaming service but it is on
netflix in new zealand so with surfshark
i can connect to a vpn server in new
zealand just like that i'm on my way to
camp crystal lake one subscription
allows you to install and run surf shark
on an unlimited number of devices at the
same time and surf shark's 30 day
money-back guarantee
gives users plenty of time to try out
their service risk-free
so if you'd like to check out
surfsharkvpn you can go to
surfshark.deals
microcosmos and enter promo code
microcosmos for an 83 discount and three
extra months for free
the names on the screen those are our
patreon patrons
and we'd like to thank each and every
one of you who has chosen to support
this channel
and if you'd like to become one of those
people you can go to patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more of
our master of microscopes james weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
instagram or also on tick tock
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby